[Musique]
jean paul ii entre la vie et la mort son
état s'est encore dégradée ces dernières
heures selon la presse italienne le pape
aurait perdu connaissance le dernier
communiqué publié il ya une heure
indique que son état général s'est
aggravée et qu'il est désormais
notablement compromis toute la
communauté catholique est en prière
depuis hier soir depuis que le vatican
annoncé la brusque détérioration de sa
santé dans ce journal avec nos envoyés
spéciaux nous serons en direct de rome
de cracovie nous irons à notre dame de
paris
et puis sur ce plateau plusieurs invités
dont le professeur bernard debré et
monseigneur dubost autres titres de
l'actualité la campagne pour le
référendum sur la constitution
européenne avec le premier grand meeting
hier à marseille de françois hollande
à marseille aussi philippe de villiers
qui lui se réjouit de l'avancée du nom
dans les sondages et puis le sidaction
en france à partir de ce soir jusqu'à
dimanche sur toutes les chaînes de
télévision la mobilisation pour lutter
contre ce fléau et bien sûr l'appel à la
générosité
enfin le groupe queen n'était en france
pour un concert unique le groupe s'est
reformé 14 ans après la mort de son
chanteur freddie mercury frappé par le
sida
un concert à guichets fermés alors que
queen il n'était pas remonté sur scène
depuis 20 ans madame monsieur bonsoir
c'est au coeur du vatican place saint
pierre devant les fenêtres du pape que
des milliers de fidèles sont en prière
ils veulent accompagner jean paul ii et
de soutenir dans son dernier voyage
cette image est sans doute la plus
symbolique de la tente une attente
presque résigné le vatican vient en
effet d'annoncer dans un dernier
communiqué qui nous est parvenu il ya
moins d'une heure que l'état de santé de
jean paul ii a été notablement compromis
les conditions générales du pape comme
le précise ce dernier bulletin se sont
aggravées le temps du deuil est proche
et on prie pour le pape à l'unisson de
ses millions de chrétiens mais pas
seulement qui dans le monde entier se
recueillent les nouvelles donc que se
succèdent depuis près de 24 heures c'est
le quatrième communiqué celui-ci ne
laisse plus vraiment d'espoir le pape
selon les agences de presse italiennes
auraient perdu connaissance tout s'est
accéléré depuis hier soir 23 heures
lorsque le vatican a publié un premier
bulletin il retiendra l'émotion du porte
parole du vatican jean paul ii attend la
mort
il était encore lucide et serein cet
après midi me dit ans bernard lebrun
visage grave visiblement préoccupé
joaquin navarro valls le porte parole du
vatican vient de rédiger le troisième
bulletin de la journée pas de conférence
de presse cette fois un simple
communiqué distribué à la presse
il est 18h30 en substance le communiqué
indique que le pape jean paul ii souffre
d'une insuffisance cardio circulatoire
et rénales que son hypertension
artérielle s'est aggravée et qu'il
respire mal déjà ce midi alors que les
spéculations vont bon train et que la
presse italienne dit le pape à l'agonie
ou dans le coma dans la salle de presse
du vatican
on se bousculait pour entendre le second
communiqué officiel du jour
il était 12h30 la situation à cette
heure est stationnaire mais les signes
d'une gravité évidente demeurent les
paramètres biologiques sont altérées sur
la pression artérielle est instable trio
chat est instable
mais le pape continue à être lucide
lucci pleinement conscient et je dois
dire et se rendre chez leurs mails
attaque a été très sérieuse dès hier le
pape jean paul ii a été victime d'une
crise de septicémie entraînant une
attaque cardiaque
pour autant il refuse de quitter ses
appartements l'alarmé si grave qu à
19h15 hier il reçoit le viatique des
malades autrement dit le saint sacrement
au petit jour le premier communiqué
officiel ne cache rien de la gravité de
la situation
il est 6h30 et starmania ce matin les
conditions de santé du saint père sont
critiques winehouse l'inquiétude grandit
d'autant plus lorsqu'il révéler la
présence au vatican de cet homme
le cardinal ruini vicaire de rome en
charge de l'annnonce de la morgue
mais un autre cardinal qui lui a visité
jean paul 2 ce matin se montre alors
rassurant immédiatement dès que le saint
père m'a aperçu il a souri à celle ci il
me reconnaissais mais l'icône ajoute que
l'on sauvé
dans le communiqué de ce soir le vatican
indique que l'état de santé du pape est
notablement compromis et de source
médicale selon l'agencé italienne en
deçà il n'y aurait plus d'espoir donc
hier soir que jean paul ii a reçu les
sacrements du malade dans un état d'une
gravité évidente selon le communiqué du
vatican
sa santé ces dernières 24 heures on l'a
dit s'est brutalement dégradé les
fidèles ont accueilli la nouvelle avec
une infinie tristesse jean paul ii qui
est chez lui à la maison dans ses
appartements entouré par la ferveur des
romains reportage isabelle staes
emmanuel bec unis dans la prière devant
la basilique saint pierre
ces pèlerins anglais sont venus se
recueillir parmi tant d'autres ici dès
qu'ils ont appris la nouvelle
on prie très fort pour le saint père dit
ce prêtre de oxford ont pris pour ses
derniers moments pour son agonie il a si
bien servi l'église
tous les regards sont braqués sur les
fenêtres des appartements du pape
depuis que jean paul ii a reçu les
sacrements du malade et fidèles n'ont
plus d'espoir sa mini jack griffin
hélas on prie pour lui en espérant
qu'elle s'améliore mais comme la
médialle 10 battant mauvaise nouvelle
d'une heure un autre l'atmosphère a
changé à rome et pas seulement parce que
toute la presse internationale est
installée près du vatican
même s'ils ne meurent pas aujourd'hui on
sent que la présence du pape s'éloigne
et pour nous qui sommes de rome c'est
encore plus important car c'est comme un
voisin
là je regarde ses fenêtres c'est comme
si je regardais les fenêtres de chez moi
chacun rend hommage à sa manière et
certains font déjà l'éloge de jean paul
ii au passé c'était un grand orateur
c'était un grand penseur c'était même un
athlète c'était un homme en bonne santé
quand il a commencé à être pape mais
maintenant il a été dépouillé de tout ça
mais même comme ça dans ces derniers
jours ces dernières semaines encore il
apparaît devant la fouille alors que
l'état de santé de jean paul ii ne cesse
de s'aggraver ce soir de plus en plus de
pèlerins convergent vers la place saint
pierre nous retrouvons gérard griesbeck
en direct de rome les derniers
communiqués se succèdent le dernier
tombé à 19 heures d'autres pourraient
suivre et le vatican a choisi
semble-t-il de multiplier les
déclarations ce qui n'est pas habituel
oui c'est pour le moins inhabituel vous
savez pendant des semaines voire un peu
plus le vatican nous avait habitués ou à
ne donner qu'une partie de la vérité ou
à ne rien dire là visiblement depuis
hier soir les choses ont changé c'est
vrai aussi que la situation de santé du
pape est tellement critique qu'on ne
peut plus la cacher et finalement on
peut dire que le vatican prépare
l'opinion publique internationale
à la mort du saint père alors c'est vrai
que finalement c'est fidèle qui
maintenant affluent sur la place st
hier et bien accompagne le mourant et le
mourant jusqu'au bout sera resté pape
aura gardé c'est sa charge et il n'y
aura donc pas renoncé
on sait donc l'importance qu'il a
accordé à cette charge
on sait l'importance qu'il accordait
aussi au fait de se montrer dans le
passé il a été l'athlète de dieu on l'a
vue sportif et bien on l'a vu toutes ces
dernières semaines agonisant on va pas
le voir évidemment mourir mais on sait
qu'à l'heure qu'il est sans doute il est
en train de mener cette dernière
bataille contre la mort merci et géra
griesbeck jean paul ii a donc choisi de
rester dans ses appartements pour y
mourir en souverain pontife un instant
il a été dit que jean paul ii était dans
le coma information très vite démentie
dans la journée alors le porte parole du
vatican a détaillé la nuit et la matinée
du pape
un papa bout de souffle et lucide l'oeil
de la marne et il est très exactement
18h17
hier soir lorsque jean paul ii reçoit le
saint viatique l'extrême onction donnés
aux malades proches de la mort mais au
cours de la nuit
l'état du saint père qui est resté
conscient se stabilise suffisamment pour
qu'il demande à 6h ce matin à
concélébrer la messe dans la chapelle
privée de ses appartements
peu de temps après ils souhaitent qu'on
lui lise les 14 stations du chemin de
croix
le récit de la passion du christ à
chaque station jean paul ii a fait le
signe de croix
dans la matinée le pape va encore
recevoir plusieurs collaborateurs en
fait essentiellement ceux de la garde
rapprochée du vatican qui assureront la
période d'intérim après son décès à
présent jean paul ii ne bouge plus de sa
chambre où ont été installés tous les
équipements médicaux
c'est chez lui que le pape veut finir
ses jours jusqu'au bout il sera
accompagné par les cinq soeurs polonaise
qui l'ont suivie depuis le début de son
pontificat
pour autant tout au long de l'après midi
le vatican a voulu montrer que la vie de
l'église suivait son cours
en publiant une liste de démission et de
nominations d'évêques que jean paul ii
avait signé juste avant l'aggravation de
son état de santé avec nous le
professeur bernard debré bonsoir on l'a
dit les communiqués se succèdent précis
des communiqués médicaux diriez vous que
selon les dernières informations le
pronostic vital du pape est engagé
que c'est évident le pavot mangeant dans
les minutes ou les heures qui viennent
il a eu cette nuit un arrêt cardiaque
c'est déjà quelque chose de très grave
il a été comme on dit en médecine parler
de moi d'utiliser ce terme rattrapé par
des médicaments qui ont été administrés
rapidement et puis progressivement du
fait de sa maladie parkinson qui avait
été bradé ses poumons serrait son coeur
progressivement ces organes sont en
train de lâcher la mort gagne et il est
en train de mourir professeur debré le
papa a souhaité mourir dans ses
appartements chez lui - l'hôpital
mourir comme le veut la tradition est ce
que ça veut dire d'une certaine ça sente
qu'il n'ya pas qu'il n'y aura pas
d'acharnement à et thérapeutique
oui bien entendu et je crois que nous
sommes tous contre l'acharnement
thérapeutique inutile à un moment donné
ou où la mort est en train de gagner je
crois qu'il est nécessaire d'accompagner
et c'est ce qui se passe avec ses
médecins qui qui font en sorte que le
pape ne souffre pas donc pour ne pas
souffrir et déjà la présence qui
réconforte et peut-être des médicaments
qui l'empêchent de souffrir peut-être un
mois avec vous et monseigneur dubost
bonsoir peut-être d'abord l'émotion de
tous les catholiques et puis l'émotion
qui est sans doute la vôtre bien sûr
vous savez en ce moment je me rappelle
les premiers mots ou à peu près de jean
paul ii n'ayez pas peur et je trouve que
c'est bon de les rappeler maintenant
parce que je crois que jean paul ii a
fait face à la vie et qu'il doit faire
face à la mort sans avoir peur ou en
dominant sa peur par sa foi et je crois
qu'il nous dit aussi n'ayez pas peur à
tous les tous les catholiques qui qui
évidemment sont en train de vivre ce
passage vers l'éternité lors tous les
catholiques et bien sûr dans le sud de
la pologne dans un petite ville natale
de jean paul ii comme partout ailleurs
dans le pays la population ce recueil
premier pape slave de l'histoire de la
chrétienté jean paul ii n'a jamais
oublié sa pologne natale la pologne qui
s'est unie dans une même ferveur de
prière autour de lech walesa ou encore
du premier ministre polonais les pollens
est toujours solidaire de leur pape
balance entre espoir et impuissance
comme le montre à cracovie ce reportage
de maryse burgot et nathalie calais
ils sont venus spontanément devant
l'archevêché de cracovie pendant des
heures ils vont prier devant une fenêtre
devenu mythique
chaque voyage de jean-paul ii dans son
pays natal pas c'est en effet par cette
fenêtre où il sentait priait avec la
foule souvent tard le soir c'était au
temps où le pape alé relativement lien
mais ce soir parce qu'il n'y a plus
d'espoir ces polonais se remémore le
passé les sanglots au bord des mots
cette femme se souvient qu'ils étaient
des milliers chaque soir il nous a donné
tant d'espoir dit elle surtout pendant
les temps difficiles du communisme c'est
une femme de 27 ans explique que jean
paul ii a été nommé pape l'année de sa
naissance
et c'est grâce à lui dit elle que notre
peuple a trouvé la liberté 95 % des
polonais sont des fervents catholiques
alors ce soir dans les 150 églises de
cracovie bien sûr on prie pour le pape
l'enfant du pays est considérée ici
comme l'homme le plus important du xxème
siècle un enfant du pays qui compte bien
sûr à cracovie des amis intimes
ce physicien faisait du ski avec jean
paul ii dans les années 50 on les voit
tissier ensemble rester proche de jean
paul ii cet homme évoque ses années où
il se cachait du régime communiste pour
dire des messes en compagnie du pape
dans des villages de montagne
c'est ici à cracovie dans les années
60-70 que karol wojtyla s'est forgé un
destin en rusant avec le pouvoir
communiste de l'époque en allant parfois
jusqu'à l'affrontement et c'est cette
attitude qui explique aujourd'hui
l'immense respect qu'il inspire au
peuple polonais il nous vous rejoignons
gilles rabin à crac'h ville le coeur de
la pologne bat au rythme des communiqués
chacun retient son souffle et peut-être
maintenant ses larmes
priscilla longtemps que le coeur de la
pologne bat au rythme des rats paroles
et des grandes souffrances de
paul ii car ici jean paul ii est
considéré comme un saint vivant un saint
vivant que bien sûr personne ne veut
voir disparaître
alors bien sûr cette fois ci tout le
monde a compris que le moment du grand
deuil était proche et tout le pays ce
recueil retient son souffle ce recueil i
prix ont pris dans toutes les églises
tous les monastères tous les lieux de
pèlerinage très nombreux en pologne bien
sûr mais elles ont pris aussi dans les
synagogues et dans les mosquées
car ce n'est pas seulement le plus grand
pape de l'histoire à des plus grands
page de l'histoire qui va disparaître
c'est aussi l'homme qui s'y incarne à
lui tout seul la fierté la liberté
retrouvée qui incarne sursaut national
qui incarne le formidable renouveau de
la pologne ces 25 dernières années
merci gilles rabin une questions à nos
invités monseigneur dubost
une information qui vient de nous
parvenir à l'instant selon le ministère
de la santé du vatican le pape est à
l'agonie et comment doit-on interpréter
cette déclaration d'un homme d'église
vous qui êtes un homme d'église je ne
suis pas médecin pour moi ça veut dire
qu'il est en train de vivre ces quelques
secondes et peut-être même que c'est en
train de se terminer mais je dirais
qu'il est il est mort quand on dit qu'il
était à l'agonie c'est à dire qu'il est
mort qu'il faut maintenant constaté la
mort alors je vais pas me placer à la
place de monseigneur dubost mais il
faudra que le camerlingue aille
constater la mort et c'est ce qu'on est
en train de faire vraisemblablement
alors ça bien sûr nous en parlerons avec
vous tous dans quelques instants
je voudrais simplement qu'on parte à
l'instant pour pour paris ou à notre
dame une messe vient d'être célébrée par
monseigneur andré vingt-trois
monseigneur vingt-trois qu'est lancé un
appel à la prière dans toutes les
paroisses de son diocèse depuis ce matin
françois jullien pieds-noirs thierry
breton
les cloches de notre dame sonne pour
jean-paul deux sets mais c'est pour lui
monseigneur andré vingt-trois archevêque
de paris a tenu à la célébrer très
important de nous réunir pour prier en
communion avec le pape qui vit une
période particulièrement difficile comme
tout être humain qui approche de sa fin
et beaucoup de chrétiens
[Musique]
cherche comment exprimer leur solidarité
leur désir d'être en communion avec lui
une cérémonie pour le peuple parisien et
pour de nombreux touristes fervent aux
curieux les fidèles beaucoup de jeunes
se pressent pour apporter leur soutien
spirituel
c'est à la fois le sauté dans son
épreuve qui vont prier pour l'église qui
est un tournant jean paul ii nous a
apporté beaucoup de choses et je n'ai
devoir de chrétien dernier à trier se
tenir le jour de l'éruption d'un énorme
que j'aimais beaucoup comme toujours et
vos prières vont être lesquels vos
pensées vont et heykel pour le monde
rires de paix corps à l'intérieur des
milliers de personnes qui se rassemblent
spontanément dans un lieu cher à jean
paul ii pas encore dommage de la
république même si l'on a pu apercevoir
les pousses du premier ministre jean
pierre raffarin alain juppé ou encore
jean tiberi comme beaucoup d'églises
parisienne la cathédrale notre dame sera
ouverte une grande partie de la nuit
les fidèles pourront venir prier pour
leurs papes
une même ferveur même qui était à lyon
une messe s'est déroulée autour de
monseigneur barbarin primat des gaules
les fidèles étaient rassemblés à la
cathédrale saint jean partons maintenant
pour lourdes où le souvenir de la visite
de jean paul ii le 15 août dernier est
encore très vivace c'est dans cette
ville qui vit dans le culte de la vierge
marie
si cher au pape que le souverain pontife
avait surmonté la maladie pour son
dernier déplacement france lourde qui
est en prière depuis ce matin isabelle
de lyon olivier combe les sanctuaires de
lourdes
le lieu de recueillement des malades
bien sûr le pape est dans tous les
coeurs
c'est à l'homme souffrant que pensent
les pèlerins la compagnie pour lui pour
qu'il s'en vend 1 p exxon abonnés ne
soit pas longue
parce qu'il a assez souffert beaucoup de
gomme et autonome vous pensez à lui
aujourd'hui
toujours en août dernier jean paul ii a
effectué ici son dernier grand voyage à
l'étranger
devant cette grotte malade mais bien
présent un souvenir plein d'émotion pour
l'évêque de lourdes l'orée d'une
nouvelle de sa présence
moi non et ce dont tout le monde
pourrait témoigner c'est la grande
sérénité qui avait autour de lui et donc
quand on nous dit aujourd'hui qu'il
accueille la mort dans la sérénité
on peut le croire les sanctuaires se
prépare à sonner le glas et à mettre
leur drapeau en berne à l'annoncé du
décès du pape une prière spéciale sera
dit au début de chaque office mais il
n'y aura pas de messe des morts la fête
de pâques se prolonge encore jusqu'à
dimanche prochain et donc la fête de
pâques l'espérance de la correction
prime sur tout le reste même sur la mort
du pape et je crois que symboliquement
ce très fort de pouvoir célébrer une
messe de la résurrection alors même que
le pape et mourront dans la ville le
temps du glas les commerçants tireront
leurs rideaux le pape était ici très
apprécié et très respecté à lourdes
l'été dernier le pape n'avait pas réussi
à cacher la terrible souffrance qui
l'étreignait images de ce combat qu'il a
livré jusqu'à ces dernières heures jean
paul ii qui avait fait huit voyages en
france le pays qui l'a le plus visité
avec sa pologne natale et c'est à
lourdes il ya quelques mois qu'il avait
annoncé qu'il sentait venue la fin de
son pèlerinage
jean marie mais c'est un pas en fauteuil
roulant quête accueillis par jacques
chirac à l'aéroport de tarbes en ce 14
août 2004 jean paul ii exprime sa joie
de ces journées un nouveau dans un pays
dont la culture et la fois dira-t-il ont
marqué l'histoire est géniale qui me
permet encore une fois j'ai chef
l'élocution du saint-père est difficile
la fatigue se lit sur son visage
mais une heure plus tard dans les rues
de lourdes y semblent revigorés par
l'accueil enthousiaste de la foule
21 ans jour pour jour après sa première
visite
jean paul ii s'agenouille devant la
grotte de massabielle là où la vierge
serait apparue à bernadette soubirous
un malaise un malaise qui ont dit non
sur la santé déclinante du pape
un peu plus tard dans la journée jean
paul ii fera lui-même allusion à sa
possible disparition
j'ai regardé si peu de la zone de marjah
bien méchant avec un chien tel le temps
d'avant en 1983 un pape alors bien
portants avait promis de revenir à
lourdes 21 ans plus tard c'est un homme
usé qui tient parole
c'était hélas jean paul ii était venu
offrir sa souffrance à une marée humaine
ultime rendez vous avec la communauté
des croyants en france et cette
souffrance est fini par voir comme
monseigneur dubost vous en avez été vous
même témoin puisque vous étiez tous les
deux à lourdes c'est à voir absolument
oui c'était très émouvant de voir c'est
un malade
parmi les malades la plupart des malades
étaient soit sur des brancards 60 ans
des petites voitures met lui même était
sur un trône roulant comme on l'a vu et
c'était extraordinaire de voir le visage
de ces gens malades qui étaient vers un
autre malade c'était en quelque sorte
qu'ils aient comprenez qui c'était
extraordinaire il ya une communion
énorme enseignants du camp de la dignité
mais je veux dire que toute la vie de
jean paul ii a été marqué par la
souffrance de souffrance de son enfance
des souffrances morales d'être orphelin
et tous ceux qui il a vécu puis toute la
maladie et vous savez qu après son
attentat il a écrit une encyclique sur
la souffrance sur le sens de la
souffrance et sur la lutte qu on doit
mener contre la souffrance mais quand
elle est là la capacité de l'offrir et
je crois que ce qu'il nous a montré que
s'il sait qu'il a été il a lutté contre
la souffrance il a voulu la vaincre et
en même temps il a été capable d'offrir
peut-être un mois sur cette
médiatisation précisément de la
souffrance celle qu'a souhaité
semble-t-il le vatican je ne sais pas
qui l'a souhaité vous savez je crois
qu'on peut dire que le pape n'avait pas
beaucoup ne donnait pas beaucoup
d'autonomie à ses proches
c'est quand ils voulaient quelque chose
il le faisait et à mon avis c'est ce
qu'il a fait de tenir jusqu'à pâques on
a fait remarquer tout à l'heure qu'il
était mort ou qu'il est en train de
mourir le jour de pâques c'est je crois
ce qu'il voulait et je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose de tout à fait important
dans son caractère est ce que c'est lui
qui les journalistes à sec 30 ans
jusqu'à maintenant mène-t-il et
médiatique alors ils urinent je vais
continuer à faire les très particulier
c'est quand les hommes malades veulent
rester en vie jusqu'à une date leur
anniversaire la revenus de le retour
d'un fils une date particulière ils y
arrivent ils ont la volonté la pugnacité
et puis quand cette date est arrivé il
s'effondre et la mort gars c'est ce qui
s'est passé et donc on va tout de suite
évoqué précisément ces deux mois de
souffrance depuis traits de cette
mauvaise grippe qui a provoqué
l'hospitalisation du pape et depuis la
détérioration de son état de santé
ce n'était de santé s'était accéléré on
gardera de cette souffrance héroïque
l'image du pape
jetant ses dernières forces me l'avait
dit vers les fidèles le jour de pâques
frédéric retard c'était il ya deux jours
la dernière apparition officielle de
jean paul ii depuis sa première
hospitalisation
début février l'état de santé du pape
n'a fait qu'empirer à la fenêtre de sa
chambre d'hôpital
il bénit la foule est temps de prendre
la parole mais les mots italiens qui
sortent de la bouche du saint père sont
incompréhensibles
alors c'est un message enregistré au
préalable par son entourage prévoyants
qui prend le relais
trois semaines plus tard jean paul ii
retrouve l'hôpital gemelli et cette fois
une trachéotomie et pratiquer le saint
père apparaît le dimanche pour bénir la
foule
on le voit porter la main à sa gorge
douloureuse il faudra attendre le 13
mars pour entendre de nouveau la voix du
souverain pontife une voix rauque mais
cette fois le message est compréhensible
son playback
le soir même qu'il quitte l'hôpital et
fait ses adieux à l'équipe médicale
qu'il est soigné une caméra filme de
loin geste de souffrance alors que jean
paul 2 vient de s'installer à bord du
véhicule qui le ramène au vatican
les conseillers en communication ont
fait placer une caméra à l'intérieur de
la voiture
jean paul ii fait bondir ses médecins en
voyageant la fenêtre ouverte
ses proches la firme le pape est lucide
mais son corps lui échappe à la fenêtre
de ses appartements le dimanche des
rameaux le saint père exprime un signe
d'impuissance en tapant sur son pupitre
le pape n'est pas en état de participer
au traditionnel chemin de croix
il apparaît cependant filmé de dos ce
qui ne fait qu'accroître l'inquiétude
sur sa santé le dimanche de pâques
il apparaît en public avec un masque de
souffrance cela râle s'échappe de sa
bouche il sera incapable de prononcer un
mot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une souffrance immense sous les yeux de
millions de catholiques partant dans
dans le nord de la france où vit une
forte communauté polonaise
là aussi émotion et recueillement
reportage marianne masse l'éffigie de
jean claude weil sur l'office du soir
ici beaucoup de polonais se recueillent
parfois seulement quelques manques les
fidèles pour témoigner leur foi et leurs
dons spirituels à celui qui souffre
aucune finish un peu au moment des faits
ses dettes on va prier pour sa bonne
jean l'épiscopat de polonais a dit nous
voulons nous unir
non aux prix ensemble parce que je pense
que les papes
aujourd'hui un besoin de notre prière de
notes le don spirituel un don spirituel
que vous couperez faire exprimer dans le
silence et le recueillement de la petite
chapelle
jean paul 2 à grands pas pour les
colonels c'est notre papy et penny qui a
menti en chine arguent lobby des armes
celui qui a commencé vraiment qu'on s'y
dit et tout le foot lui mais chrétien
choix en chambre ensemble tout ce
week-end les polonais de la région vont
prier pour leurs papes
ce dimanche sera un jour particulier
avec la fête de la miséricorde une fête
instituée par jean paul ii lui-même élu
pape le 16 octobre 1978 karol wojtyla a
été ordonné prêtre à cracovie puis
évêques archevêques et cardinal enfin
son élection à la tête de l'église a été
une surprise et une fierté pour cette
pologne qui est toujours resté très
présent dans son coeur à cracovie comme
à varsovie le pays est portée par une
ferveur nationale caroline gauthier
karol wojtyla n'a jamais oublié les
siens alors aujourd'hui à wadowice et sa
ville natale
toutes les prières vont vers cet homme
que certains ont côtoyé avant qu'il ne
devienne le premier pape polonais
nous sommes très inquiet depuis ma
petite enfance ici à l'église je me
souviens de lui quand il était prêtre
évêque cardinal il venait souvent nous
voir
zakopane dans les montagnes un des lieux
préférés du souverain pontife
montagnards des touristes s'y
recueillent hésitant entre l'espoir et
la résignation c'est tout un pays qui
souffre pour son pape et partage sa
douleur ici à czestochowa des dizaines
d'adolescents sont venus supplié la
vierge noire si chère à jean paul 2 et 6
7 5
crédité de nombreux miracles pouvait
répondre à leurs suppliques de prague
l'ancien président polonais lech walesa
veut lui encore croire à un miracle
restons calmes moi je suis croyant je
fais confiance aux décisions du bon dieu
et j'ai encore l'espoir que le saint
père s'en sortira et qu'il continuera à
nous servir
et puis en irak à des milliers de
kilomètres de là sur cette base
militaire les 4000 soldats polonais
engagés dans le conflit ont posé les
armes
le temps de cette prière pour que leur
pape retrouve la paix non le compte vous
êtes biographe du pape jean paul 2
d'après vos informations est votre
sentiment
pensez vous que jean paul ii aurait
secrètement souhaité s'éteindre en
pologne peut-être est inhumé en pologne
s'éteindront pologne il peut être pas il
a il s'est toujours remis dans les mains
de dieu là dessus le temps pour la date
que pour le lieu en revanche il a gardé
vous avez raison une très grande
affection pour son pays et on sait bien
que s'il n'avait pas eu cette carrière
en quelque sorte il serait entrée au
carmel en pologne et à plusieurs
reprises lors des voyages en pologne on
s'est demandé si en effet il n'aurait
pas
rêver quelque part de finir sa vie dans
un carmel en pologne
bon il en a décidé autrement il a dit
c'est dieu qui décidera et comme vous le
savez il a ni démissionné ni choisi le
car mais alors comment la pologne sera
sera auprès de du saint père qui est
vraisemblablement décédé selon cette
dernière information
l'électrocardiogramme du pape et place
selon la presse italienne il n'y a pas
de commentaire du vatican à méplat ont
parlé d'agonie maintenant on parle
électrocardiogramme plat il est mort et
je crois qu'il faut maintenant constaté
sa mort c'était un moule tristesse non
efforcé de lyon ne peut pas dire autre
chose
comment vont se dérouler ces heures qui
viennent oui alors d'abord il ya
l'entourage très proche c'est comme la
mort d'un père dans une famille il y a
son secrétaire qui est à la fois son
chef de cabinet étaient sont et son fils
spirituel stanislaw dziwisz qui est là
évidemment d'attentionné on imagine tout
près et très ému il ya les petites
soeurs qui l'ont servi pendant ses 26
ans les petites soeurs les petites
religieuses polonaises petite soeur de
l'enfant jésus qui sont là toujours
attentionné qui sont des vieilles femmes
maintenant elle aussi était jeune il ya
26 ans et puis il y à d'autres prélats
d'autres il ya le celui qu on appelle le
porte-plume monseigneur ulrich aux c'est
celui çi jusqu'à la fin a écrit les
textes du pape
tout cela fait un entourage il faut pas
parler de cas marilia ou de ou de
filières ou de je ne sais pas quoi on
exagère toujours un petit peu ce côté là
c'est surtout la famille du pape
ce pape qui a tellement parlé de la
famille et qui lui même était sans
famille depuis si longtemps c'était sa
famille ces polonais qui l'entouraient
fini par voir peut-être d'un mot qui
sera chargé d'annoncer la mort du pape
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir que le pain depuis 1996 avait pris
toutes les dispositions concernant la
vacance du siège apostolique
les obsèques auront lieu entre trois et
six jours avait il demandé
mais des prières seront dites pendant
neuf jours le conclave chargé d'élire
son successeur se réunira entre 15 et 20
jours après sa mort et l'intérim du
pouvoir est évidemment confié aux
caméras lundi la nonne et le camerling
qui est un cardinal espagnol monseigneur
martinez au maroc est âgé de 78 ans
c'est lui qui devra constater qui est
peut-être en ce moment en train de
constater le décès du pape
et puis si lui qui va convoquer la
réunion des cardinaux qui dès le
lendemain de la mort du pape vont se
réunir pour préparer le conclave c'est à
dire l'élection de son successeur
si vous voulez bien tout de suite retour
à rome où dans toutes les églises les
fidèles sont en prière au tour de la
classe politique vide et philippe
visseyrias et romain potocki messe de
soutien ou déjà messe d'adieu autour du
cardinal camillo ruini toute l'italie se
retrouvent ce soir à l'église saint-jean
du latran le président de la république
le chef du gouvernement l'opposition
tous unis dans la prière dans ces heures
de souffrance comme avant donc tout son
infatigable ministère le pape voit déjà
le seigneur il est déjà uni à notre seul
sauveur dans la ville éternelle aux 900
église l'émotion est partout des prières
spéciales sont organisées dans les
paroisses de quartier depuis 26 ans les
italiens sont sous le charme de ce pape
polonais qu'ils ne veulent pas voir
partir
c'est comme si c'était une personne de
ma famille qui est en train de mourir et
donc je ressens le besoin en ce moment
de prier pour lui et pour ce qu'il a
fait
ce sont les enfants de la génération
jean paul ii dans le centre san lorenzo
à rome créée par le pape lui-même ces
jeunes accompagnant prière la lente
agonie du saint père
est on
on est dans la paix dans la sérénité
même si c'est un mystère la mort est un
mystère on accompagne le saint père dans
ce passage à saint louis des français
l'église de la communauté française de
rome le recteur s'est fait une raison et
parle déjà de jean paul ii au passé
certes les devises continuera mais elle
a bien vécu et que cet homme pendant
bien des années et elle ne peut pas ne
pas regretter voir il est temps que il
regagne la maison du père depuis deux
mois les fidèles à rome vivent au rythme
des bulletins de santé du pape avec le
temps l'espoir de le voir guérir s'est
amenuisé et ce soir ils se préparent au
pire avec fatalisme il nous vous
retrouvons en direct de la place saint
pierre et isabelle cesse j'imagine que
l'émotion et l'angoissé grandit depuis
les derniers bulletins
écoutez béatrice jeu
actuellement devant les fenêtres des
appartements pontificaux qui se trouve
juste derrière moi et qui domine la
place saint pierre depuis à la tombée du
jour les fenêtres des appartements
qu'occupe le pape sont allumés elles
sont toujours allumé ce soir et en bas
sur la place saint-pierre et bien
plusieurs centaines de fidèles se sont
rassemblés
il n'y a pas pour l'instant de grands
grands mouvements de foule mais on
entend d'ores et déjà ses fidèles prier
et chanter les yeux rivés sur les
fenêtres des appartements de jean paul
ii et qui probablement guette un signe
le signe qui les plongera dans le deuil
alors pour l'instant il ya ici beaucoup
d'italiens qui ont écouté les nouvelles
toute la journée et qui sont venus ce
soir rendre visite à jean paul ii comme
on rendrait visite à un malade un proche
qui probablement vont passer la nuit ici
à veiller sous les fenêtres du pape
et puis il ya aussi des pèlerins
étrangers nous avons rencontré tout à
l'heure un groupe de français qui
finalement résume assez bien le
sentiment de la plupart des fidèles qui
sont ici les on dit c'est la fin mais
c'est mieux ici car même si c'est le
pape c'est avant tout la souffrance d'un
homme
il est temps que cette souffrance
s'arrête merci isabelle cesse vous
restez avec nous peut-être d'un moment
seigneur du boss vous ai vu et écouté
avec beaucoup d'attention le son des
cloches que l'on entendait derrière
isabelle 16 précisément ce que voulait
dire quelque chose je n'en sais rien ce
que je sais c'est que pour moi elle
m'invite d'une certaine manière et je
pense qu'elle invite beaucoup de
chrétiens à prier pour le pape savait
quand on on veille quelqu'un qui va
mourir ou qui est en train de mourir ou
qui vient juste de mourir ont dit des
prières très simple d absolute ya 3000
ans et qui dit des profondeurs je crie
vers toi seigneur écoute mon appel et b
au fond je pense qu'il est temps de dire
cette prière et d'écouté de te demander
au seigneur d'écouter notre appel pour
qu'il passe dans la tête
ce n'est pas revoir cet appel semble
venir d'ailleurs des images que l'on
voit que l'on voyait il faut savoir que
c'est le cardinal ruini cayla vicaire de
rome qui est en charge d'annoncer la
mort du pape donc tant qu'il n'aura pas
annoncé cette mort du pape pour moi
chrétienté pour tout le monde
le pape n'est pas encore mort peut-être
l'at-il cliniquement mais pas
officiellement en tout cas car le
cardinal ruini c'est le vicaire de rome
et le pape est aussi l'évêque de rome on
entend des chants place saint-pierre
dans les images que nous sommes en train
de découvrir avec vous en direct mais
pas je ne les entend pas bien mais ce
que je sais c'est que j'imagine que
c'est les prières que l'on dit dans ces
moments là et qui sont très importantes
pour pacifier aussi ceux qui sont autour
ce que ça doit être
on dit dans le désespoir houle c'est la
tristesse mais c'est aussi d'espérance
ses terres que nous croyons que il est
attendu et que pour lui il a fini un
pèlerinage difficile et que il rentre
dans la lumière du père un jour de
pâques le saint père était était
d'ailleurs un patient sans doute en
j'imagine qu'il a pour lui c'était plus
il était c'est un homme qui aime le
travail et donc il ne refusez pas le
travail mais c'est quand même tout ça la
densité de sapir montré combien il était
attaché à celui bien avec lui
je note que vous en parlait à
l'imparfait l'impression que
malheureusement certains girl annonce
d'annoncé officielle du vatican
je crois qu'ils ont été divisées deux
choses et une part ce communiqué qui dit
qu'il ya un électroencéphalogramme plat
que peut-on en déduire le nicolas
bouvier n'en pas le vatican
bien sûr mais il ya le cérémonial et
philippe harrouard je dis bien on ne
peut pas l'annoncer tant que ce n'a pas
été constaté par les autorités
officielles et ça va être constatée
d'une minute à l'autre d'ailleurs
on peut dire que il ya très longtemps
pour constater la mort du pape le
camerlingue avait un petit marteau
d'argent et frappé trois fois sur le
front du pape pour voir si l'âme encore
des réactions en l'appelant par son
prénom en l'appelant par son prénom
exactement bon ça ne se fait plus
maintenant je suppose que le cercle acte
de décès signé par un ou deux ou trois
médecins suffira mais il faut quand même
un certain cérémonial il faut que le
vicaire de rome
'l'annonce d'abord aux proches qui parle
c'est vrai ce faire aurore en pleine
nuit par exemple se fera cette nuit même
humblement mesdames avant il faut
également qu'ils s'adressent au corps
diplomatique qu'il envoie des des
télégrammes je ne sais comment ou qui
voit les ambassadeurs pour leur annoncer
la mort du pape et ensuite ils annoncent
publiquement
donc ça peut prendre un peu de temps
mais certainement effectivement que le
pape est décédé ont noté mais on était
dans dans la journée c'est cette
attitude du vatican en fait qui a
beaucoup changé
il y avait des nominations et des
démissions annoncées par le vatican
aujourd'hui comme si tous tourner
normalement j'allais dire oui ça je
crois que ça fait partie de ces excès de
zèle qui caractérise les entourages de
tous les chefs d'état c'était vrai au
moment de la mort de pompidou dus à la
maladie de mitterrand c'était vrai sous
tito sous brejnev souffrent coup on a
toujours connu ça et et le vatican et
s'il est le plus petit état du monde
c'est quand même un état avec ses
entourages et c'est exceptionnel si vous
voulez bien on va partir et on quitte la
place saint pierre pour pour retrouver
des millions de fidèles qui sont
également rassemblés en prière en fait
depuis hier soir de moscow brésil en
passant par les philippines et les etats
unis chacun accompagne par la prière
l'agonie de jean paul ii florence bost
pierre aux états unis au coeur de
manhattan la santé du pape fait la une
des panneaux publicitaires comme tant
d'autres villes dans le monde new york
s'est réveillé dans la tristesse prière
et recueillement à la cathédrale saint
patrick
ce matin nous prions pour notre pape
jean paul ii des prières partout dans le
monde au brésil le plus grand pays
catholique
les fidèles se sont recueillis toute la
nuit et ce matin
d'autres les ont remplacés aux
philippines les cierges brûle sans
faiblir
on prie pour le pape pour qu'il puisse
mourir sans souffrir à tout ce que dieu
décide toute l'église doit l'accepter en
irak aujourd'hui les chrétiens oublie
jusqu'à leur propre situation
leurs pensées ouvert jean paul ii au
nigeria comme dans tout le continent
noir même ferveur afin que le pape plus
s'éteindre dans la sérénité
majestueuse la cathédrale de cologne en
allemagne accueille tous ceux et ils
sont nombreux ici qu'ils se sont touchés
par le destin hors du commun de ce pape
est très faible
j'ai une photo très précieuse pour moi
car j'ai eu l'immense chance de
rencontrer le pape et de lui serrer la
main et je n'oublierai jamais cette
poignée de main il m'a la fois douce et
faire abba fest dans toutes les villes
d'espagne les églises sont pleines
depuis louvre je trouve que c'est très
triste qui est en train de se passer
mais tous ceux qui sont croyants savent
bien qu'aujourd'hui il meurt et que
demain il renaîtra au portugal à fatima
la des lieux de pèlerinage préférés de
jean paul ii une messe spéciale a été
dit pour ce pape d'exception à jérusalem
dans l'église du saint sépulcre c'était
aujourd'hui jour de prière spéciale pour
la santé du pape jean paul ii qui a
beaucoup marqué les esprits lors de son
voyage en israël en mars 2000 la
communauté catholique et compte quelques
cent mille personnes en israël et dans
les territoires
et puis apparaît cet état lors de la
grande prière du vendredi les musulmans
français ont évoqué jean paul 2 et prier
pour lui comme le monde ce reportage à
la grande mosquée et un orgue et olivier
robert une doigt une invocation au dieu
des musulmans pour jean paul 2 cet après
midi à l'heure de leur grande
célébration hebdomadaire ses fidèles ont
prié pour le pape et adressé un message
aux catholiques de solidarité avec la
communauté chrétienne
c'est une première à la grande mosquée
de paris
ah on a tous appris en partage les
sentiments de toutes les religions
c'est une religion monte donc par là
même il est adroit à la considération
des mesures c'est quelqu'un d'important
quand même dans nos demandes religieuses
en national puis voilà je voulais c'est
un grand talent qui est en train de
partir c'est tout il a été toujours pour
justement une
une solidarité entre les religions une
compréhension entre les religions et
voilà c'est un symptôme un chef
spirituel qui a beaucoup oeuvré pour le
rapprochement entre les musulmans et les
chrétiens
c'est aussi pour cela confirmer que
dédiée aujourd'hui houmous est l'homme
du dialogue instauré entre les religions
un homme d'une extrême sympathie pour
l'islam d'une extrême bienveillance pour
même parfois la cause des musulmans
l'hommage au chef de file des
catholiques rendu par une autre religion
ce formidable travail du pape qui a
instauré le dialogue avec différentes
communautés communauté chrétienne mais
aussi en dehors des communautés
chrétiennes
oui ce qui restera de lui dans les
livres d'histoire dans son temps c'est
ce qu'il a fait pour le rapprochement
entre juifs et chrétiens
là on n'est pas dans la dans l'actualité
on est dans une histoire de 2000 en 2000
en d'incompréhension de méfiance de
mépris que ce pape là celui qui venait
de pologne qui avait dans sa jeunesse
des petits copains juifs qui a eu des
partenaires de théâtre juive qui
connaissait très bien le sujet qui a été
archi archevêque de cracovie
n'oublions pas kosice l'aide chinoise
c'est ce pas plat qui aura fait le plus
court le rapprochement entre juifs et
chrétiens plus aucun de ces un travail
de repentance de l'église bien entendu
l'un va de pair avec l'autre au moment
du passage au troisième millénaire quand
il lance sa repentance
l'un des dossiers les plus importantes
de cette repentance porte sur l'attitude
des chrétiens dans l'anti judaïsme et
ses conséquences ça ça restera une très
grande étape dans l'histoire mais deux
grandes images 1986 le pape jean paul ii
peinait dans la synagogue de rome
on n'avait jamais vu cela et puis plus
récemment lorsqu'il est allé à jérusalem
il est allé s'incliner devant le mur des
lamentations à jérusalem est là ni dans
l'interstice le petit message que l'on
met toujours que tous les pèlerins mais
là je me gratte ou pratt
la plupart du temps et puis également il
a été dans des mosquées l'était dans les
pays musulmans
il a fait un travail absolument
considérable dans le dialogue non
seulement entre chrétiens
même si on peut dire qu'avec les
orthodoxes a pas toujours très bien
marché mais également de dialogue
interreligieux avec les autres religions
musulmane juive entre autres de réponse
est assise à 6,2 de réunions d'assises
qui sont quand même assez extraordinaire
dès lors la travée banques les religions
représentés et priant les unes à côté
des autres c'est quand même un spectacle
et pour la paix alors celle-ci vous bien
je vous propose tout de suite d'écoutés
l'abbé pierre qui est qui vit lui les
derniers instants du pape comme un
soulagement on écoute tout seul tu
n'aimes ne veulent pas désiré
qu'approche la fin de ce france qui
s'enchaînent et il s'accumule et non
parce que je même dans la vénération
qu'elle m'inspire mais dans l'affection
aussi les cheveux blancs produits jeu
j'aspirais à ce que vienne le moment où
ils se feraient plus car il ya des prix
que ça vient pour tiens on ne confirme
qu'il a encore toute sa lucidité
ça ne m'étonne pas fait car il n'était
capable d'une activité intellectuelle
considérable
la plupart de ces documents des
encycliques d'autres documents bon ça
marque
bien sûr elle par phinney par deux
châteaux ria mais c'est véritablement sa
pensée qui nous a été communiquée toulon
saab est vite et il me retrouve ont à
présent direct de lyon monseigneur
barbarin bonsoir vous êtes primat des
gaules
vous allez sans doute partir j'imagine
dans les heures qui viennent pour homme
avait servi dans les jours qui viennent
là je sors de la cathédrale où il y
avait beaucoup de monde qui étaient
venus pour prier pour le pape
on sentait une grande affection de tout
le monde pour lui ce qui est normal je
suis très heureux de parler juste après
l'abbé pierre qui est un enfant de lyon
et qui a grandi ici et avec qui je me
suis entretenu au téléphone il ya juste
un jour ou deux et de sentir aussi son
affection pour le saint-père et les
lyonnais sont venus très nombreux ce
soir la cathédrale pour pour confier à
la vierge marie les les dernières heures
de du pape maintenant et à l'heure de
notre mort sainte marie mère de dieu
priez pour nous donc nous allons prier
pour lui et nous l'avons confié à sa
prière à elle et puis demain nous
ouvrirons toute la basilique de
fourvière pour pour lui pour que les
gens puissent venir prier signé et
manifester leur affection saint-père
leur gratitude à dieu aussi pour ce beau
serviteur dont nous avons vu la trace
lumineuse au milieu de nous dans la
cathédrale tout à l'heure il y avait mon
seigneur ces geeks a donné l'homme est
lié et il a comparé la fois du pape un
chêne du xxème siècle c'était très beau
on sentait aussi une vraie action de
grâce dans son coeur et puis lundi nous
éviterons tout le monde dans la
cathédrale de ce qu'ils veulent pour et
puis je partir à rome ensuite oui
j'aimerais entendre peut-être un
sentiment plus personnel comment vous
vivez la disparition annoncée jean paul
2 écoutez avec double sentiment un peu
contradictoire alors le premier c'est la
nostalgie quand même parce que je me
souviens que moi par exemple qui suis
archevêque de lyon maintenant la
première fois je suis venu à lyon c'est
en 1981 6 avec tout les jeunes de mon
aumônerie comme j'étais aumônier de
lycée et on était venu à gerland où il y
avait deux rassemblements du pape on
avait allumé le briquet on avait chanté
comme c'est un immense concert il y
avait justement le concert de jean
michel jarre dans cette ville alors que
le parc des princes quelques années
auparavant donc mille souvenirs des
choses si intenses vécus avec le peuple
nous reviennent forcément comme quand
quelqu'un qu'on aime beaucoup s'en va
donc ça c'est de la tristesse ou de la
nostalgie ou la douleur d'une séparation
lié à l'affection qu'on porte à
quelqu'un et en même temps bien sûr dans
ma foi une profonde gratitude parce que
moi je suis heureux d'avoir vu la fois
la solidité de ce successeur de pierre
jésus dit dans l'évangile et la à pierre
il lui dit quand tu seras revenu
fortifie tes frères dans la foi
et on peut dire que jean paul ii bat il
a vraiment été un bon successeur de
pierre et qu'il a fortifié ses frères
dans la foi plus en plus de cela il a
travaillé à l'unité à la rencontre entre
les chrétiens à la rencontre entre les
religions à la prière commune au
dialogue
en plus il a été un extraordinaire
serviteur des pauvres dans le monde
entier il a parcouru sans cela c'est le
mexique et l'afrique et l'ensemble du
monde vont défendre cette cause pour
être la voix des sans voix si on peut
dire non c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
oui j'en parlais avec la version on sent
la passion dans chacun de vos propos je
me permets de vous couper car je
voudrais que l'on retourne à rome où
nous retrouvons notre correspondant
gérard griesbeck
il semble que des informations plutôt
contradictoire où nous parviennent est
ce que nous sommes de gérard je ne vous
remettra tandis à joseph bamba triste on
a des informations contradictoires c'est
à dire qu'on nous dit qu en réalité rien
n'est sûr que finalement la formation
sur l'encéphalogramme plat a été donnée
par une agence italienne mais n'a pas
été confirmée vous savez ici on nous dit
que finalement enfin c'est vrai que ce
pape qui est là maintenant depuis
presque 27 ans est difficile de faire
des comparaisons sur les morts de pâtes
mais c'est vrai que l' annonce de la
mort d'un pape dans le passé c'est fait
ou par communiqué hooper intervention
d'un porte parole
et lorsque le vicaire de rome annonce à
la foule
le pape est mort et là en l'occurrence
ça devrait être effectivement le
cardinal ruini et bien c'est un peu
formel c'est à dire en réalité les gens
le savent déjà
donc on attend et on se dit que
finalement si on doit la prendre
on la prendra peut-être par le bureau de
presse du vatican ou par camion à
communiquer par une déclaration de
joaquin navarro valls avant que le
cardinal ruini lui-même n'exprime
publiquement et vous restez évidemment
avec nous pour ce journal qui devient
une édition spéciale drake on retourne
en france depuis les journées mondiales
de la jeunesse en 1997 une nouvelle
ferveur est née chez des jeunes
catholiques qu'ils n'ont connu en fait
que le règne de jean paul ii leur rendit
dominique bonnet elle est venue exprès
pour prier pour jean paul 2 cet après
midi comme de nombreux jeunes
catholiques delphine est venu soutenir
le pape par le seul moyen sa disposition
c'est la prière tous les jours et
effectivement maintenant il est
librement dans l'est dans les bras de
dieu
dans la génération jean paul ii jamais
collé puis on allait aux jmj on l'a
toujours suivi
donc c'est vraiment un guide en 97 de
nombreux jeunes français ont
effectivement rencontré le saint père à
paris où ils étaient un million journées
mondiales de la jeunesse
parmi eux françois si aujourd'hui il
suit avec compassion la fin de vie du
pape c'est parce qu'il a été marqué par
le personnage le pape à chaque fois
qu'il viendra nous rencontrer nous les
jeunes il nous propose la révolution de
l'amour
ils nous proposent de mettre le christ
au coeur de notre vie et il est bien
placé pour en parler parce que il a
suivi il a il a vécu toutes les grandes
épreuves de l'histoire du 20e siècle
damien lui aussi avait participé aux jmj
pour voir ce pape qui plaît tant aux
jeunes
je pense qu'en fait on est dans une
génération ou en tout cas en occident on
a tout ce qu'il faut en terme d'argent
bien par contre il ya beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup d'amis et qu'il manque un sens
je pense que ce pape en défendant goutte
que route un certain nombre d'options a
voulu montrer qu'il était possible
d'avoir un sens à ta asie beaucoup de
ces jeunes sont allés assister ce soir
la messe célébrée pour jean paul ii à la
cathédrale notre dame de paris et unir
ainsi leurs prières à celle du reste de
l'église seigneur du mal j'ai évidemment
envie de réagir
la jeunesse forte elle portait lé pape
dans sa douleur on a vu un lourd mais
ailleurs également
c'était une des voies importantes de ces
voyages multiples depuis le début de son
pontificat il a fait très attention aux
jeunes
vous savez que le concile vatican ii et
le premier concile qui s'est occupé des
jeunes qui a fait un message pour les
jeunes est vraiment jean paul ii à
porter ce message
j'aimerais dire que non seulement il a
été populaire mais il leur a posé des
questions et il les a invités est vrai
avec eux mêmes et je crois que c'est la
clé de son succès car il était vrai lui
et il disait des choses
en s'appuyant sur l'espoir que les
autres enfin c'était vrai et il a et
c'est cette schola est important le
charisme du pape devant ces millions de
jeunes finalement on avait l'impression
d'assister pratiquement dès des concerts
le rock en fait c'est comme ça qu'ils le
voulaient c'était une grande messe pour
les jeunes ça restera un des plus
extraordinaires paradoxe de ce pape dont
le discours le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est qu'il est exigeant c'est ce leader
d'opinion et et le moins démagogues de
tous les leaders d'opinion et pourtant
quand il parle aux jeunes dit la
symphonie 800000 un million de jeunes
qui viennent l'écouter
ça veut pas dire évidemment que tous ces
jeunes dimanche suivant vont aller à la
messe
mais ça veut dire qu'il leur parle en
effet comme personne ne leur parle du
bien du mal d'une façon très directe
mais en même temps un pack très
conformisme réactionnaire attendit
parler aux jeunes il était contre
l'avortement on parle du sidaction qui
va se dérouler à partir de demain fait à
partir d'aujourd'hui tout ce week-end on
sait à quel point le pape ait eu des
réactions très réservée et très
critiquée des francs qu'il faut se
méfier de l'étiquette réactionnaire et
puis il faut aussi savoir que dit
l'église là dessus parce que du cardinal
lustiger archevêque de paris jusqu'à
georges cottier le cardinal qui est le
théologien du pape
tous disent si vous ne pouvez pas vous
contenir mettez le je crois qu'il faut
quand même rappeler sa très fort
le pape lui être au dessus ils brassent
la ligne d'horizon il dit le rapport
sexuel c'est être plus beaux au monde et
pour qu'ils soient beaux pure qui soins
dont total et absolu il faut paquet de
contraint donc le préservatif et
condamna mais encore une fois il y a
l'idéal que tracent le pas et puis à la
réalité
la faiblesse des hommes les épidémies et
ça c'est les évêques si j'ose dire
monseigneur qui s'y colle alors l'amour
on finit par voir avant de commenter
des images qui nous parviennent dans le
direct de la place saint-pierre jiang
que c'est lui qui a créé les jeux
journées mondiales de la jeunesse c'est
comme ça qui s'est imposé comme le pape
d'une génération
n'oublions pas que c'est le pape qui a
poursuivi sa mission pendant plus de 26
ans 26 ans et demi donc le pape de toute
une génération et c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire
vos souvenirs du parc des princes avant
les faits le souvenir de 1975 avant le
jmj il a il a toujours voulu parler aux
jeunes et parler un langage de vérité
mais je crois que justement ce qu'on est
né en lui celle qu il avait pas les
approcher une marque de fabrique était
aussi un pape qui était un athlète
quand on a vu arriver il était jeune et
c'était un athlète extraordinaire dieu
est ce parce qu'elle vient espériez de
dieu on le voyait faire du ski hees
avait changé bouleversé l'image des
papes qui étaient plutôt des maps un peu
dans leur curie romaine
jusque là c'était un pape qui a été tout
à fait moderne alors il a eu un langage
qu'il a eu c'est un langage de l'église
à 58 ans je me souviens d'un gamin qui
disaient qu'ils ont dû demander qu'est
ce que c'était qu'un pape et il avait
répondu c'est un homme qui rend hommage
à dieu en voyageant c'est en effet une
très belle définition
tu voulais bien vais essayer de voir ce
qui va se passer après car la mort
imminente de jean paul ii est avéré
après débutera un interrègne d'au moins
deux semaines avec l'élection du nouveau
pape au cours du conclave
le conclave qui se déroule dans la
chapelle sixtine samah soula
lorsque les portes de la chapelle
sixtine se refermeront sur les cardinaux
l'élection d'un nouveau pape commencera
20 jours au maximum après le décès du
saint père sous l'oeil du jugement
dernier de michel-ange réunis en
conclave les cardinaux électeurs ceux
qui ont moins de 80 ans vêtu de pourpre
voteront deux fois le matin deux fois le
soir totalement coupés du monde mais
avant cette période de huit clos les 117
cardinaux électeurs procéderont à
d'intenses consultations
presque tous ont été nommés par jean
paul ii en fait les hommes pour pro
venus du monde entier se connaissent mal
ils recevront tour à tour des prêtres
des responsables de congrégations
religieuses et même des laïcs dans ce
sacré collège l'europe est le continent
le plus représenté mais elle n'a pas la
majorité absolue
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'église les cardinaux peuvent élire
l'un des leurs un prêtre ou même un line
qu'à la majorité des deux tiers
lorsque les cardinaux tombent d'accord
sur un nom les bulletins sont jetés dans
de la paille mouiller pour qu'une fumée
blanche s'échappe sur la cité du vatican
nous avons un pape annonce alors le
proto diacre quelques minutes après le
nouveau papa parer à la fenêtre de la
basilique saint pierre
comme jean paul ii en 1978 lorsqu'il fut
présenté aux fidèles
karol wojtyla était alors un cardinal
inconnu nous étions ya quelques instants
en direct de lyon avec monseigneur
barbarin qui n'ont va partir pour rome
puisqu'il sera l'un des plus jeunes à
voter cinq français je crois en plus en
présent absolument sous les 117
cardinaux de moins de 80 ans il ya cinq
français le cardinal barbarin on vient
de le voir archevêque de lyon le
cardinal panafieu archevêque de
marseille
le cardinal lustiger ancien archevêque
de paris qui à 78 ans le cardinal tauran
qui est bibliothécaire au vatican et le
cardinal paul poupard qui est président
du conseil de la culture
voilà donc cinq cardinaux français il y
aura on a vu une vingtaine de cardinaux
italiens et on l'a dit pour la première
fois les européens ne seront pas
majoritaires
alors quel repas jouer au jeu des
pronostics serait évidemment indécent
mais néanmoins comment comment peut-on
imaginer l'élection de ce prochain pape
on a dit qu'il y aurait une forme
d'alternance après un trait une très
longue période comme celle de gaillac
avec qui jean paul 2 on choisira
peut-être un pape âgé ce que c'est c'est
vraisemblable c'est souvent une période
plus court ça je crois que le jeu des
pronostics cela on s'est toujours
trompée à chaque élection pas pour s'est
trompé sauf une fois où mon jardin
non ce qu'on peut dire il faut pas nous
avancer des noms c'est pas le tiercé en
revanche il ya une vraie problématique
de l'église catholique aujourd'hui qui
est à 87 % dans l'hémisphère sud
c'est à dire que la catholicité
aujourd'hui c'est l'amérique latine
c'est l'afrique c'est l'un de ces les
philippines et c'est de là que devrait
probablement venir le prochain pas
peut-être cette fois-ci peut-être la
fois d'après ce que jean paul ii aura
réalisé c'est la mondialisation de
l'église
il aura au fond accompagnés la
mondialisation notre planète par la
mondialisation de l'église aujourd'hui
ça serait pas étonnant du tout d'avoir
un pape africain ou métis ont dit que
ces derniers mois il avait préparé
derrière ses succès sciences vous êtes
d'accord avec cette année moi je ne
crois pas à ces analyses là je ne crois
pas que le pape prépare sa succession il
a en 26 ans mondialisée l'église cette
église est mondiale et le parviendra de
quelque part dans le monde ait ben idir
que en principe qui est saint-esprit qui
décide un qui aident en tout cas les
cardinaux à choisir un nouveau pas alors
le saint-esprit temps en temps la des
clins d'oeil
par exemple on avait dit effectivement
qu'après de longs règnes il faut un pape
disons qu'il ya un assez âgés et qui
dure peut rappeler pie xii longue et on
avait trouvé jean xxiii un pape qui
venait de venise qui était bon enfant
bon qu'elle n'est pas qu'elle ait pas
faire grand chose
il a fait le concile c'est quand même
assez extraordinaire est ce qu'on oublie
aussi c'est que après paul 6 s'était pas
jean paul ii qui devait régner gens
s'étaient jean paul 1er et la nar est
absolument donc c'est à eux on peut pas
dire grand chose
bon simplement on peut quand même
constater une chose c'est que
là où il ya le plus de catholiques c'est
en amérique latine il y à des candidats
certainement très sérieux en amérique
latine s'ils voulaient dh les interrompt
un instant bas tout de suite repartir
vers rome gérard griesbeck
quelles sont les dernières informations
écoutait les informations qu'on a ici
c'est que finalement les choses dures
c'est à dire que sur la place
saint-pierre effectivement de plus en
plus de pèlerins viennent et prix et
chante et on voit maintenant cette place
quasiment noir de monde
en revanche du côté du vatican on n'a
aucune information c'est à dire qu'on a
toujours ces deux fenêtres que sans
doute vous devez voir les appartements
du pack toujours éclairés mais non
seulement nous n'avons pas d'information
mais la salle de presse du vatican est
maintenant vide et on ne donne pas deux
prochains rendez vous merci gérard
grisey que j'aurais peut-être d'un mot
parler de cette phrase que j'ai noté du
cardinal lustiger
il a dit on ne comprend rien jean-paul
du si on ignore qu'il passe au moins
trois heures par jour en prière et en
fait il prend ses décisions dans le
secret de cette chapelle et non pas à
son bureau est ce que vous êtes d'accord
aussi avec moi je voudrais cette analyse
je ne sais pas si les trois heures mais
ce que je sais c'est que chaque fois que
je les ai vu un petit peu dans la durée
je l' ai vu prier avec une intensité qui
était tout à fait remarquable et de fait
je suis sûr que pour lui la prière et le
lien paroles échangées vers dieu et
quelque chose était quelque chose ou est
quelque chose de tout à fait fondamental
c'est pour ça que d'une certaine manière
pour moi je suis triste de la mort du
pape pour lui
je crois que c'est un jour heureux
bernard lecomte
il est vrai que jean paul ii aura été un
pasteur il a été professeur il a été
poète journaliste il a été comédien il
il a il a été aumônier des étudiants
mais en effet le gardien du si j'ai
raison on ne comprend pas l'homme si on
ne sait pas qu'il est en plus un
mystique qui a failli plusieurs fois
entrée au carmel et qui a été d'abord et
avant tout un homme de prière
c'était aussi un peuple du monde c'est
du premier pape cacher autant de voyages
la pac est allé à la rencontre des
jeunes lisent et ça c'est tout à fait
examiner la n'y a pas d'autres
extérieurs il a pris le monde comme une
paroisse donc il est allé partout alors
je devrais peut-être que l'on que l'on
retrouve ces images que l'on voit des
saint-pierre donc nous sommes en direct
cette place et et noir demande tous ses
fidèles qui convergent depuis hier soir
vers cette place ont entendu sans doute
les nouvelles extrêmement préoccupante
de la santé du peuple je ne sais pas si
pour ils sont en prière sachant que le
pape est mort peut-être ne l'at-il pas
c'est vrai qu'on me disait les
communiqués sont tout à fait
contradictoires
est ce que peut être vous pouvez me
commenter ces images on a le sentiment
qu'on saignant dubosc il y va y avoir
une déclaration
il ya quelqu'un qui est en train de
faire prier j'ai l'impression l'ensemble
des gens qui sont sur la place et je
crois que ceci est tout à fait logique
est tout à fait important et contrer
tout invite ceux qui sont devant leur
téléviseur et qu'ils sont catholiques en
faire autant les leviers que j'étais
abonnement la mort de paul vi et de
jean-paul premier puisque c'était en
1978 est ce qui m'avait frappé c'est que
sur cette place saint pierre
au début il ya personne et en une
seconde
cette place se remplit les gens viennent
tous ensemble comme s'il y avait un
appel pour prier vendor il pas d'argent
frais il fit six string aura quatre ses
enfants
quand le père mais shinji nakano ses
enfants et par approche est pris et
coxyde et d'icônes on l'a fait et il
exprime ainsi l'ami radio n'est leurs
remerciements leur foi et nous voulons
le faire ce soir nous allons le faire ce
soir ensemble street autour du à saint
père hal saint-aubin autour de cette
place le 16 octobre 1981
18 ans en 1989 de cette journée grid en
a pas ouvert qu'un terroriste ses
fenêtres ce soir cette nuit on peut se
le christ christ ouvre aussi les
fenêtres à jean paul ii à la seconde et
la porte mais certainement il ya aussi
marie support les singes de mer la bad
est il à dire la cua les je suis et one
sont tout autour
elle a dit je suis à toi mon histrion à
tourner le singe chapelet et vézien
moment et régnant autour du saint père
et nous voyons
marie sa mère qui nie vide
jésus est donc et nous confirmons la
danse après ces paroles par notre prière
ne me donne pas au nom du père figure du
film the spirit orgie du saint-esprit
monseigneur dubost donc cette prière est
dit par un évêque semble utile il ne
s'agit pas du vicaire pas de ces
notamment seigneur venir
yves dit simplement le je vous salue
marie vous savez c est alors la vierge
marie pour lui c'est le modèle de la
fois c'est le modèle du oui total entier
et il a voulu être totus tous vous
souvenez sa devise est totalement à toi
et je crois que c'est très beau de prier
le je vous salue marie simplement
maintenant une paroi quand même pas mal
de commentaires sur ces images donc la
place saint pierre où se sont réunis ces
milliers de fidèles et le terrain ils
sont en train de prier tous
et alors il n'y a pas que des italiens
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'étrangers
avant d'y placer 2 c
le pape universel à l'universalité ce
qui est près d'elle pour prier et au
moment où il doit retrouver sans doute
très bientôt la maison du père
donc c'est ça qui est aussi important et
comment aussi important on a beaucoup
insisté sur la vierge marie comme vous
l'avez fait mon seigneur mais c'est de
savoir que lors de son dernier voyage
c'était à lourdes et il a prié dans la
grotte de massabielle
et il fallait voir le pape dans ces
grottes il était aux frais de la vierge
véritablement qu'il a tant aimée et
c'est ça qui était extraordinaire au
sein est ce qu'on peut imaginer que ces
prières peuvent durer toute la nuit
ce que les fidèles et les hommes
d'église vont accompagner le se passe a
certainement que les libyens vont durer
toute la nuit
je vois un des responsables du conseil
des laïcs qui est en train de griller
je crois qu'il vaut mieux comprendre que
ne pas pas refuser mon cher le mans
thérapeutique et que là il était en
train de s'éteindre seul et si tout est
fait de le savoir
nous sommes en train d'assister à
l'agonie naturelles et les hommes qui
sont autour de lui n'ont que la prière
surtout je crois pas que les médecins
agi sous ou font quelque chose si ce
n'est peut-être de l'empêcher de
souffrir et mourir dans ses appartements
et de refuser de retourner je n'ai
jamais entendu et c'est pour ça que
c'est aussi long et ce matin ce matin il
a demandé à lorsqu'il était encore
lucide il a demandé que l'on lise
l'évangile de la passion si vous voulez
bien je le faisais interrompre parce que
voilà une dépêche qui nous parvient et
cela est d'une importance le vatican
dément les allégations de la presse
selon lesquelles le pape serait mort
donc en réalité la presse italienne
d'une chose le vatican ne confirme pas
cette prière semble accompagner l'agonie
du pape
ils sont deux faces allemand et ce qui
est normal et sans doute pas sa mort
claire dans le compte du contenu dans
l'histoire l'heure exacte de la mort du
pape
n'a aucune importance ce qui me frappe
ce soir ce qui fera probablement tous
les téléspectateurs c'est que un peu
comme dans la chanson d'aznavour vous
avez ils sont venus ils sont tous là il
ya le monde entier au chevet du pape
toutes ces communautés dans tous les
pays autour des églises dans les
cathédrales qui prit très simplement ce
grand père qui est en train de les
quitter
il ya ce côté familial qui me frappe moi
qui est tout à fait unique c'est rare
dans notre monde ce genre de moments et
c'est ce moment là me semble-t-il qui
restera je partais aimeriez être tiens
j'aimerais aussi et rêverie avec les
gens second diocèse parce que c'est là
que je trouve que c'est important d'être
et ont ils ont pris est alors le
chapelet je crois que dans les
déclarants twitter qui viennent il
faudra qu'on soit ensemble les parents
et au public le pape est la seule grande
autorité morale du monde entier à
l'heure actuelle avec tous les voyages
qu'il a fait du sud c'est normal que non
pour le les autres aussi parce qu'il est
allé partout d'être reçu par les chefs
d'état de toutes ne sont pas catholiques
il est allé partout et on l'écoutait on
venait le voir et donc c'est en cela que
aujourd'hui sa mort
la saône agonie en tout cas dépasser
largement le monde catholique le monde
chrétien
il ya beaucoup de gens certainement
qu'ils sont très émus ce soir de voir
cet homme de la paix ont consulté pour
des problèmes de pet de droits de
l'homme
normal quand on a envie de dire que dati
gantois est peut-être très embarrassé de
la suite à donner
dans cette espèce de transition qui ne
dit pas son nom
en réalité le vatican ça fait 2000 en
question la succession de pape jean paul
ii et le 264e pape
il y aura deux cent soixante cerf volant
doit il ya aucun doute là dessus
non je crois pas que cet arrière assez
s'annonçait la gestion de toute toute
fin d'un grand homme d'un chef d'état
d'un leader spirituel il ya toujours des
petites maladresses ici ou là je suis
sûr qu'en ce moment on s'interroge en
effet auprès de lui pour ses grosses
pincettes on annonce ce soir ou cette
nuit ou demain matin bien sûr mais cela
dit si on vous dit actuellement moore il
est pas encore mort il est pas encore
mort attendons en effet l'annoncé
officielle pour lire le pape est mort
voila voila vous noté mais vous savez il
a donné un rendez vous cet été à cologne
aux journées mondiales de la jeunesse
et je pense que en voyant ces images
beaucoup se diront les nécessaire
probablement d'y aller non seulement
pour accueillir le nouveau à ce moment
là il ya main mais pour aussi rendre
hommage à celui qui les a tenté mais
peut-être une dernière question à chacun
d'entre vous quelle est l'image de ce
pape qui a régné pendant 26 ans quelle
est l'image que vous avez envie vous de
retenir et puis je n'aurais la même
chose à la bernard debré bien vous aimez
tous les invités sinon tu veux dire que
l'image du pape au mur des lamentations
et provenant celle qui frappe tous les
esprits
et puis j'ai beaucoup d'image puisque
j'ai eu la chance de l'approcher pour
l'enterrement les journées mondiales de
la jeunesse
mais qu'il y a dans le coin de mon coeur
quelques traits d'humour parce que il
nous a fait souvent rire nous amener au
plus profond qui nous a menés au plus
haut nous a fait réfléchir et nous a
fait aussi souvent rire bernard debré
s'est vu à tous
là aussi nous effet répondre à la baisse
c'était un monde
puis vint monde fourier une foule
extraordinaire vu des mots d'humour et
il savait mener est due à la fois la
spirit est doté d'humour
moi je l'image que je garderai c'est
l'image que j'ai eu quand j'étais jeune
journaliste et que j'ai couvert pour mon
journal de l'époque la croix le premier
voyage du pape derrière le rideau de fer
en juin 69 ces foules 1 500 mille six
cent mille huit cent mille personnes qui
étaient là dans un pays communiste pour
moi journaliste je suis là il se passe
quelque chose et tous les journalistes
qui étaient là tous les confrères qui
est la catho pas qu'à touba peas ou papa
puisse tous se sont dit on est en train
d'assister à quelques à un événement
historique et moi c'est l'as rome
lorsqu'il a été installé
donc en octobre 78 et qu'il a dit cette
phrase extraordinaire n'ayez pas peur on
ne savait pas très bien ce que ça
voulait dire on se doutait que ça
voulait certainement dire quelque chose
et on l'a vu alors dans ce que voulait
dire c'est à dire c'était n'ayez pas
peur mais c'était un grand g
en fait c'était son c'était d'un
programme politique et son message et un
programme de rigueur
il n'a pas eu peur et certainement que
si le le mur de berlin est tombé là
c'est de parler en faire 10 grâce à lui
ça ça ne fait aucun doute
si vous voulez bien repartir vers rome
nous voyons donc ces images de la place
saint pierre avec tous ces milliers de
fidèles en prière
je vais peut-être n'entendez-vous je
vous entends document donc on l'a dit le
vatican dément absolument
catégoriquement ce qu'il appelle des
allégations de la presse italienne le
pape donc n'est pas mort ce soir pour le
vatican et le pape en tout cas pour le
vatican n'est pas donc officiellement
mort vous savez bien avant un peu
glacial qui s'élevait maintenant sur la
place saint-pierre mais vous voyez de
vos propres aux yeux à quel point ça ne
change rien à quel point maintenant ces
milliers de pèlerins sont prêts à passer
la nuit en prière pour aider ce passage
du saint père de la vie à la mort
quelles sont en question des prières
monseigneur dubost qui peuvent être
dites est en ce moment même
vous avez vu le chapelet et à mon avis
il sera alternée par avec des psaumes
puisque c'est traditionnellement comme
cela que l'on veille et les mourants des
psaumes et par le chapelet c'est que bon
le pas à créer beaucoup de cardinaux 232
ans 9 consistoire et aussi le pape a été
un faiseur de saints
il a fait plus de 5 e tous les autres
pape qui l'ont précédé il a inventé une
fois et 476 canonisation comme si le
pape voulait dire attendez il faut pas
vous soyez tout seul
il ya des gens extraordinaires qui vous
ont précédés vous les chrétiens et qui
vous a vient parfois reprocher mais qui
sont des modèles en même temps il ça
voulait dire vraiment quelque chose de
très important
un sein c'est quelqu'un qui vit
l'évangile dans son époque et un saint
est obligé d'inventer quelque chose dans
la fidélité à l'amour de dieu et à mon
avis d'une certaine manière jean paul ii
a pris ça comme programme
et puis les saints nous le pensons nous
aide
eh bien je pense que jean paul ii
continuera nous aider cette
communication et qui sait ce que c'est
que la communication c'est très bien
aussi ce que c'est que le monde du
people et et quand ils donnent des
saints aux nouvelles communautés
chrétiennes quand ils donnent des saints
la jeunesse après tout bas il leur dit
peut-être que entre madonna et mère
teresa ont peut-être choisir la seconde
on écoutait à nouveau les prières saint
pierre ce jour cette prière à la vierge
marie
cette vierge marie qu'il aimait tant
qu'ils étaient donc un tel cas qui l'a
accompagné tout au long de son
pontificat tout au long de son
pontificat il avait une spiritualité qui
a été formé et où il a une spiritualité
qui a été formé par sa louis marie
grignion de montfort crétins saint
français et il explique dans un de ses
derniers livres comment il l'a découvert
et comment il est rentré dans cette
manière de
d'appréhender mari qui fait qu'elle est
un modèle de foi et de de don de soi et
que le coeur de marie est occupée
simplement de son fils et c'est ce qu'il
a voulu vivre et elle veut être
surveillé un cas dans les prières des
fidèles place saint-pierre
c'est vrai que la dévotion du pape à la
vierge quelque chose exceptionnelle mais
enfin il ya d'autres pays que la pologne
où ça se passe et c'est le cas de la
plupart des catholiques et aussi
d'ailleurs des orthodoxes qui ont une
grande dévotion à l'égard de la vierge
des vierges noires sont aussi orthodoxe
que catholiques mais c'est aussi cette
cette dévotion qui échappent parfois à
l'entendement notamment de nous les
journalistes quand on voit que ce pape
attribuant incontestablement sa survie
au moment de l'attentât de 1981 à notre
dame de fatima à la vierge de fatima et
on lui fera pas dire le contraire
alors là on sort un peu du rationnel
c'est sa conviction sa foi sa prière qui
fait qu elle a dit je ne sais toujours
pas qui a tenu larmes mais je sais qu'il
a dévié et il a toujours dit c'est la
vierge de fatima
c'est là qu'on est dans la foi et et
qu'on n'est plus dans le dernier il
avait avant d'oser la balle qui a donc
touché le saint-père qu'on a retirés est
à fatima maintenant la balle de
l'attentât de 1981 s'ils voulaient bien
on va essayer maintenant de faire un
point d'essayer de s'y retrouver dans
tous ces communiqués qui ne sont
parvenus depuis 24 heures maintenant
c'est communiquer on se sont accélérées
on a parlé de la mort du pape en tout
cas la presse italienne le disait
démenti du vatican il ya quelques
minutes on tente de faire un point avec
bernard libre
voici l'homme qui annoncera la mort du
pape le cardinal camillo ruini vicaire
de rome et donc de son évêque
jean paul ii qui en cette soirée sans
espoir a convié les paroissiens de saint
jean de latran à la prière même chose
sur la place saint pierre avec ce groupe
de pèlerins anglais qui prie et qui
attendent le dénouement fatal visage
grave visiblement préoccupé joaquin
navarro valls le porte parole du vatican
vient de rédiger le dernier bulletin de
la journée il est 18h30
pas de conférence de presse cette fois
un simple communiqué distribué à la
presse qui parle d'aggravation en
substance il indique que le pape jean
paul ii souffre d'une insuffisance
cardio circulatoire et rénales et que
son hypotension artérielle s'est
aggravée et qu'il respire mal dans son
homélie ce soir le cardinal ruini qui a
vu le pape à deux reprises dans la
journée s'est montré pessimiste
et quand le pape voit déjà et tous déjà
le seigneur dit le cardinal
mais c'est dans la joie qu'ils
l'annoncent temps pour les catholiques
la vie sur terre n'est qu'un passage
dans le dernier communiqué de la soirée
le vatican indique que l'état de santé
du pape je cite et notablement compromis
de source médicale
selon l'agencé de presse italienne ansa
il n'y aurait plus d'espoir quant au
ministre de la santé du vatican le
cardinal lozano
le pape est à l'agonie vient il de
déclarer québec bien nous repartons vers
vous vous êtes toujours en direct de
rome
ces communiqués donc son successifs
quelles sont les dernières informations
qui nous sont parvenues
toujours rien de la part du vatican rien
d'officiel mais vous voyez que petit à
petit je pense vous avez encore ces
images de la place saint-pierre petit à
petit bien cette place se remplit
alors quand elle est pleine il ya
soixante dix mille personnes mais on
peut penser qu'il n'y en aura sans doute
un peu plus encore dans les heures qui
viennent puisque le cardinal ruini tout
à l'heure le vicaire de rome a appelé à
prier toute la nuit à venir sur la place
saint-pierre pour accompagner et aider
le saint père dans ce moment terrible
et c'est vrai que si on regarde ces
groupes de jeunes qui arrivent bien
évidemment il ya beaucoup d'italiens
mais on reconnaît aussi beaucoup de
groupes de l'espagnol beaucoup de
groupes de français également
ce sont les mêmes qui ces derniers jours
venaient sur la place saint-pierre pour
accueillir pour chanter les louanges du
pab le savaient ils sont sur cette place
et il brillait jean paul jean paul ce
qui paraît incroyable pour un pas mais
c'est cette relation très particulière
qu'ont les jeunes avec le saint père et
bien aujourd'hui évidemment on les
entend pas crier on ne les entend pas
sauter de joie lorsqu'il apparaissait à
la fenêtre mais tout simplement les
entends prier et ils vont rester là s'il
le faut et bien toute la nuit
nous allons aller encore plus près de
cette place saint pierre où vous êtes
vous isabelle ce test où près de deux
ses fidèles qui sont rassemblés qui sont
dans le recueillement et qui suivent les
prières des évêques
oui bah écoute et béatrice je viens
justement de descendre de la place saint
pierre jusqu'au château saint-ange par
la via della conciliazione russe de la
conciliation et je peux vous dire que
j'ai croisé des dizaines probablement
même des centaines de fidèles qui
remontait en courant cette rue pour se
rassembler sur la place saint pierre qui
était déjà évidemment plein de monde
donc il y avait des familles des petits
enfants des personnes âgées
on a l'impression que tout rhum
convergent ce soir vers la vers la place
saint pierre il ya aussi bien évidemment
des ecclésiastiques nous avons 3 et des
dizaines de légionnaires du christ qui
courait et qui nous ont dit venir du
monde entier et qui se précipitait vers
la place saint piat vous savez
légionnaires du christ et cette garde
rapprochée
on peut dire de jean paul ii est là où
je me trouve il y a encore des des
dizaines de personnes le flot ne
s'interrompt pas pense que les gens
évidemment à apprennent la nouvelle au
fur et à mesure et tout le monde
tous les romains sortent de chez eux
parce que ce sont effectivement
essentiellement des des romains pour
l'instant des familles entières qui
convergent vers la place saint pierre
pour participer à cette messe bien
évidemment puisque le carnet alouini a
appelé à ce que tout le monde viennent
prier éveillé ce soir sur la place saint
pierre sous les fenêtres de jean paul ii
le bcs comment va se dérouler cette nuit
cette nuit à rome toute la nuit les
prières balle dans wii toute la nuit en
prière probablement vous savez bon
évidemment tous les ans on pourrait dire
que tous les romains sont catholiques en
tout cas très très très proche de jean
paul ii jean paul jean paul ii pour eux
c'est un voisin
et c'est vrai beaucoup de gens nous ont
dit de toute façon aujourd'hui on vient
veillée approche on vient veya voisin
rome aujourd'hui n'est n'est plus tout à
fait comme d'habitude de l'atmosphère a
changé donc ces familles vont
probablement rester une bonne partie de
la nuit sur la place saint piat en
attendant bien évidemment un signe des
nouvelles qu'il qui les plonge un signe
qui les plongera dans le deuil voilà
mais on s'attend bien évidemment à une
très longue nuit de veiller ici sur la
place saint pierre cette veillée qui est
donc qui se fait en direct devant les
caméras du monde entier c'est sans doute
cette nouveauté puisque la presse et les
médias sont là présents pour vivre je
dirais seconde par seconde l'évolution
de l'état de santé du pape
oui mais l'agonie de jean paul ii reste
très digne ça n'a pas toujours été le
cas
l'agonie de pie xii en 1958 a été
quelque chose d'épouvantable ça s'est
passé à castel gandolfo là la famille du
pape la famille réel du pape avait pris
tous les pouvoirs rien ne pouvait se
faire sans eux
un des médecins a photographié le pape
sur son lit de mort il a vendu la photo
un journal italien ça fait un scandale
absolument si bien que après lorsque
jean xxiii a été peuple succès sur le
2012 et que lui même est mort très peu
de temps il a régné simplement que cinq
ans il avait bien pris soin de faire en
sorte que son agonie soit absolument
digne là aussi je vous adore j'aurais
quand même assister sur cette force des
médias ces caméras du monde entier qui
ont montré la souffrance du pape cette
souffrance et ses dernières forces qu'il
a jetté on l'a vu ce dimanche de pâques
et puis aujourd'hui ce soir en est en
direct de la place saint pierre avec
tous ses fidèles qui prient et
finalement c'est l'importance des médias
lui s'en est servi la rue lulli c'est la
continuité les caméras du monde entier
nous le montre depuis le début ils nous
l'ont montré sportif champion de ski et
nous l'ont montré dynamique courant des
marathons mondiaux dans ses voyages et
les mêmes caméras nous l'ont montré
souffrent et aujourd'hui ces caméras
transmettre cette cette veillée qui est
une vieille d'agonie ce qui est
important c'est que le parkinson une
comptable très longue et une déchéance
n'atteint pas le cerveau en toc telle la
réflexion et les parkinsoniens aucune
volonté extraordinaire et une volonté d
exister au niveau noté d'apparaître de
paraître et on a vu le pape dans ses
derniers moments
hier encore et avant-hier vouloir parler
s'exprimer c'est une volonté parce que
sans cerveau fonctionne rien moi je
voulais dire que dans seigneur les
images que nous voyons en ce moment
place saint pierre à rome
c'est un message de foi c'est un très
grand message de foi dans la vie c'est
un message universel c'est à dire que je
crois que comme le papa était partout on
le reçoit partout comme quelqu'un qui a
été chez vous et qui vous connaît et ça
je crois que c'est très important ça va
être catholique étymologiquement ça veut
dire être ouvert à tous
on peut dire que ce pape les a forcés à
être un peu tous catholiques de ce point
de vue là des merdes à un con cet ancien
journaliste a toujours voulu a toujours
compris a toujours su ce que c'était que
la communication et c'est l'image qu'il
donne et je pense qu'il faut bien
comprendre que l'image de l'homme de
l'homme la grandeur de l'homme la
primauté de l'homme donné par jean paul
2 c'est l'homme sportif du début c'est
l'homme à nous rendre la fin c'est le
même homme
il n'y a pas de différence dans la vie
d'un homme entre sa jeunesse quand il
est en bonne santé quand il est bronzé
quand il fait du ski et puis la
vieillesse et puis quand il est
handicapé bientôt grabataire quand il
peut plus parler quand il pleuvait
marché c'est le même homme
il est aussi grand au début qu'à la fin
c'est ça son message si vous disiez je
voudrais que qu'on regarde un peu on a
parlé de soleure de cet homme de
dialogue ces thèmes que ce pape qui a
ouvert le dialogue entre les différentes
communautés chrétiennes mais pas
seulement
le point avec elie norbert pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
douze représentants de religions
différentes ont prié côte à côte
c'était à assise en 1986 venus des cinq
continents musulmans bouddhistes juifs
catholiques entre autres répondent à
l'appel du pape jean paul ii s'unir dans
la prière pour la paix dans le monde
le paradis c'est quand même une
assurance mal de changements de
conversion allons-y rencontrons nous est
dit le fait d'être côte à côte pour la
prière des gens de différentes religions
il n'a jamais dit des prix ensemble
parce qu'ils n'ont pas pris ensemble
je suis musulman chrétien mais ils
étaient ensemble à assise dans des lieux
différents être côte à nous ça veut dire
nous nous croyons que la démarche
spirituelle à une force extraordinaire
pour la paix mondiale et que la toile
se rapprocher des autres religions une
priorité papale pendant 27 ans ici en
l'an 2000 à jérusalem
le saint-père pris devant le mur des
lamentations lieu sacré du judaïsme
puis quelques heures plus tard il se
recueille sur l'esplanade des mosquées
troisième lieu saint de l'islam
respecter la liberté de conscience la
religion de l'autre
c'est l'exemple qu'a donné jean paul ii
tout au long de son pontificat
pour lui seul le dialogue peut empêcher
le conflit c'est aussi pour la paix
mondiale la paix mondiale parce que on
le dit quand même et quelquefois s'est
pas complètement fou que c'est sa
trousse les conflits trouvent leur
origine dans des dents les religions moi
je pense qu'il faut préciser je crois
plutôt que les conflits trouvent leur
origine dans une perversion des
religions parce que aucun chrétien aucun
musulman aucun juif peut se réclamer de
dieu pour déclarer la guerre pour les
3600 s'engager par la parole mais aussi
par les actes
c'est la méthode de jean paul ii pour
entretenir le dialogue entre les
différentes religions comme ici à
canterbury en 1982 le saint père n'a pas
hésité à embrasser l'archevêque de
canterbury et chef de l'église anglicane
pour montrer qu'au delà des divergences
doctrinales le chemin à suivre pour les
hommes du monde entier
c'est le respect le pape jean paul ii
pape polonais qui était allé à auch mix
qui a et fait son premier voyage à
auschwitz lors du début de son
pontificat une relation très
particulière avec les juifs et la
communauté juive et les narguer
c'est l'une des images les plus fortes
du pontificat de jean paul ii entre les
pierres du mur des lamentations à
jérusalem
il glisse une prière comme le font les
juifs du monde entier c'est le texte de
la repentance de l'église catholique à
l'égard du peuple juif un symbole très
fort de l'amitié qui existe qui se
développe de façon tout à fait
remarquable et admirable entre juifs et
chrétiens ce pèlerinage en terre sainte
est exceptionnel depuis 1964
aucun pape ne s'était rendu en israël un
état que l'église refusait alors de
reconnaître c'est un grand pas vers la
réconciliation
et puis il ya cette demande de pardon à
dieu pour la shoah et le recueillement à
yad vashem le mémorial de l'holocauste
jamais un pape n'avait autant fait en
direction du peuple juif
ce peuple que l'église catholique a jugé
responsable de la mort du christ pendant
des siècles
ce n'est qu'en 1965 que le concile
vatican ii ballet officiellement
l'accusation mais le document final ne
mentionne ni l'holocauste ni la possible
responsabilité de l'église
il faudra attendre 1998 et la parution
d'un rapport commandé dix ans plus tôt
par jean paul ii pour connaître la
version officielle du vatican
oui des chrétiens ont bien été impliqué
dans la déportation mais à titre
individuel dans ces quelques pages
rien sur le rôle de l'institution
catholique ni sur celui du pape de la
seconde guerre mondiale pie xii
silencieux quand l'italie de mussolini
promu que ces lois raciales en 1938
restés muets alors que plus de 8000
juifs italiens sont déportés vers les
camps d'extermination nazis en 1943 la
raison qu'ils ont toujours donné pour le
silence du pape ca de maillots ramallah
détente pour éviter des crimes plus
grand mais qu'est ce qui pouvait être
pire que dallas et à auschwitz avant
tout jean paul ii n'a jamais condamné
son prédécesseur peut-être parce que la
controverse est loin d'être tranché
le pape et l'église dans son ensemble
ont aidé beaucoup les personnes
persécutées j'aimerais peut supputer
après la fin de la guerre et la
communauté est juif à remercier
publiquement puis 12 pour son
intervention la vérité se trouve
peut-être dans ses archives du vatican
jean paul ii les uns entrouverte mais
les documents des années 1939-1945
garderont leurs secrets plusieurs années
encore c'est toute l'ambiguïté de ce
pape
ardent défenseur du rapprochement avec
les juifs premier de toute l'histoire de
la chrétienté à entrer dans une
synagogue celle de rome en 1986 mais
aussi accusé de passivité
quand éclate la sphère du carmel
d'office depuis 1984 un voile terni
l'image de l'église
celui de huy carmélites polonaise elles
ont élu domicile à l'intérieur du camp
de concentration d'auschwitz
soutenu par l'épiscopat polonais la
polémique fait rage
mais il faudra attendre neuf ans avant
que jean paul ii exigent leur départ
malgré les notes dissonantes l'effort de
réconciliation est incontestable janvier
commémoration des 60 ans de la
libération du camp d'auschwitz-birkenau
dans la même cérémonie
mon chez katsav le président israélien
et le représentant du pape l'église
catholique est profondément attristé par
la haine les actes de persécution et les
manifestations dans dix initi exprimés
contre les juifs par des chrétiens
en tout temps et en tout lieu une fois
encore pas un mot sur la reconnaissance
du rôle de l'église pendant la guerre
en 1979 dans ce même quand le jeune pape
jean paul ii célébrer une messe devant
un million de polonais mais les seules
fleurs sur pour un catholique le père
maximilien kolbe qui offrit sa vie en
échange de celle d'un déporté
[Musique]
si vous voulez d'abord un mot
monseigneur dubost jean paul ii a vécu
en fait son enfance dans un milieu où il
y avait beaucoup de juifs
on oublie toujours qu'à auschwitz avant
la guerre il y avait presque 60% de
juifs et que à wadowice chez le pape
était je suis il y avait de nombreux
juifs et qu'il a des camarades de classe
des camarades de toute sa vie qui était
juif et qui sont restés ses amis
jusqu'au bout et jure qu'en envoyant ces
images je ne pouvais m'empêcher de
voyages que j'ai faits il ya quinze
jours ou trois semaines avec le rabbin
qui est en essonne et un groupe de juifs
et de chrétiens de l'essonne ç'aurait
été strictement impensable il ya 15 ans
et j'allais dire que je ne serai trop
dire combien c'est important pour la
paix du monde et pour la vérité
d'ailleurs que nous ayons vécu ces
moments là ensemble avant de repartir
pour un bain dernier mot il quand on
pense que avant le concile vatican 2 et
chrétiens parler des juifs comme du
peuple déicide et que tout a changé au
moment de vatican ii le pape d'idées en
2001 vous êtes nos frères préféré aux
juifs et d'une certaine manière nous et
nos frères aînés et il faut pas oublier
que le vendredi saint dans ses neuf
prière que l'on dit pour le monde entier
il ya une prière spéciale pour nos
frères juifs
alors merci à vous tous vous restez
encore avec nous quelques instants
retour vers un ver hommes vers vous
isabelle cesse vous êtes tout près de la
place saint pierre oui tout à fait
béatrice et jeu
vous dire que depuis à peu près une
heure il y à un flot continu de fidèles
qui se rendent sur la place saint-pierre
qui passe juste à côté nous beaucoup
d'italiens bien sûr qu'ils ont entendu
les loups qui ont suivi les nouvelles à
la télévision et puis qui sont qui sont
sorties en famille et il ya aussi des
français des groupes de français qui
était en pèlerinage à rome pour ces
fêtes de pâques et qui ont bien
évidemment sont venus ici dire qu'ils
ont entendu la nouvelle je crois qu'on
peut dire que tout rhum convergent vers
la place saint pierre ce soir tout le
monde se rend là-bas pour pour prier
ensemble sous les fenêtres du pape et
pour veiller probablement toute une
partie animée
vous savez jean paul ii pour pour les
romains c'est un voisin c'est un proche
donc ils viennent de témoigner leur
affection et leur foi
merci merci la veste s merci de nous
avoir suivi une édition spéciale
certainement un peu longue mais qui
méritait évidemment que nous rendions
compte de la situation à rome la
dernière information c'est celle ci le
vatican dément que le pape soit mort en
tout cas pour l'instant une agonie très
certainement roman prière des dernières
informations et évidemment dans le
journal de la nuit dans un instant là
même la météo nathalie roux et puis le
point route de et puis quand à moi
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain dès 13h excellente 500 et sur
français
[Musique]
on